- Des images choquantes :
des trous de balle dans la
façade d'une garderie de l'est
de Montréal. Un rappel du danger
que représentent les armes
à feu, selon Justin Trudeau.
- Heureusement, personne n'a été
blessé, mais ça aurait pu être
tragique.
- L'entrée en matière du premier
ministre, le jour du dépôt
d'un projet de loi majeur sur
le contrôle des armes au pays.
Le gouvernement Trudeau annonce
un gel national des armes
de poing dès l'automne.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Aujourd'hui, on va de l'avant
avec un projet de loi qui va
faire en sorte qu'il ne sera
plus possible d'acheter,
de vendre, de transférer
ou d'exporter des armes de poing
au Canada.
- Une mesure pour éviter
que 55 000 armes s'ajoutent
a a a a année à celles
qui sont déjà en circulation.
Les propriétaires qui détiennent
légalement des armes de poing
pourront les conserver. Ottawa
interdit aussi les cha
de plus de cinq cartouches
pour les armes d'épaule
et prévoit des peines maximales
plus sévères pour le trafic
d'armes passant de 10 à 14 ans
de prison.
DAVID LAMETTI,
ministre de la Justice
- Nous savons que pour réduire
l'accès aux armes à feu
illégales, nous devons réduire
le trafic d'armes
à nos frontières.
- Ottawa veut aussi s'attaquer
à la violence familiale
en facilitant la saisie d'armes
d'une personne menaçante
pour son entourage.
Après des années de combat
pour llelelelelele des armes,
cette survivante de
Polytechnique parle d'une étape
importante, spécialement le gel
touchant les armes de poing.
NATHALIE PROVOST,
porte-parole PolySeSouvient
- On assume notre responsabilité
et on annonce un gel,
donc le robinet est fermé.
BOUFELDJA BENABDALLAH, Centrecuc
- C'est historique, on n'a
jamais assisté à ça, que le
gouvernement se décide enfin.
- La mairesse de Montréal
aimerait qlelelelelelele encore
plus loin. Valérie Plante écrit:
Déjà, les militants pro-armes
promettent de s'adresser aux
tribunaux pour contester la loi.
GUY MORIN, Tnnnnnnn
registre québécois des armes
- C'est vraiment une attaque
frontale contre les
propriétaires d'armes à feu,
contre la possession légale des
armes à feu. Et c'est quelque
chose que... Ça passera pas.
C'est quelque chose qu'ils
vont... qu'ils vont payer pour
politiquement dans leshahahahah.
- D'ici l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi, il prévoit que
les acheteurs vont se ruer
sur les items bientôt interdits.
- C'est sûr et certain que
les ventes d'armes de poing
et de chargeurs déjà existants
vont exploser, c'est évident.
- Aux yeux conservateurs,
c'est l'idéologie qui guide le
gouvernement et pas la sécurité
publique.
LUC BERTHOLD, chef adjoint du
Parti conservateur du Canada
- Bien, je pense qu'au lieu de
consacrer autant de ressourcescs
qui possèdent des armes à feu,
le gouvernement devrait
consacrer plus de ressources
à lutter contre les gangs de
rue, à luttrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrafic
des armes illégalles.
- Les libéraux, eux,
parlent d'un jour historique.
MARCO MENDICINO,
ministre de la Sécurité publique
- La mesure la plus importante
prise au Canada en matière
de violence armée
depuis une génération.
- Un autre volet importantlelelt
toujours attendre. Ottawa promet
que son programme de rachat
obligatoire pour les armes
d'assaut sera en vigueur d'ici
la fin de l'année. M
gouvernement Trudeau doit aussi
trouver une façon d'empêcher
que les fusils interdits
soient aussitôt remplacés
par de nouveaux modèles.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Raio-Canada, Ottawa.